evan from norway has asked me to do
another u-substitution problem and i
like these because it gets my momentum
going for doing other things that maybe
take a little bit more preparation and
the problem he sent me and i hope i
pronounced his name right was
the indefinite integral of sine of x
sine of x
over
the cosine
of x
squared
dx this could also be written as let's
see he wrote an email so i don't know
how he exactly saw it but it could also
be written as
sine of x
over
cosine squared of x sometimes it's
written like that
either way i like looking at this bit
better it's a little bit less ambiguous
but in general you know to do u
substitution or
or integration by substitution when you
see something and you see its derivative
sitting there right you're like wow if
this cosine of x was just an x or if it
was just a u this would be a really easy
integral to do and we know how to do
this integral let me do it on the side
this integral would be easy 1
over
x squared
dx we know how to do that that would
just be the anti-derivative of x squared
this is the same thing as
the anti-derivative of x to the minus 2
dx and we know how to take the
anti-derivative of something like that
you increase the exponent by 1 and then
you multiply by what your new exponent
is right so it would be
minus
x
i'm sorry you increase your exponent by
one and then you divide by whatever your
new exponent is so it'd be
you would let me do the increasing the
exponent x to the minus two you increase
the exponent you get x to the minus one
and then when you divide this by minus 1
you get this minus out front and then of
course you'd have the plus c and if you
don't believe it take the derivative
negative 1 times
minus 1
that's a positive and then you decrease
the exponent by 1 you get x to the minus
2. so if we could get it in a form that
looks like this we'd be all set
and you kind of do see a pattern where
this x is you have a cosine there
and then we have cosine's derivative
there so that's the big clue that we
should be using u substitution
so let's do that what we're going to do
is we're going to substitute u for
cosine of x so if we say
u
is equal to
cosine
of x
and let's take the derivative of u with
respect to x
so d u
d x
is equal to what what's the derivative
of cosine of x it's not quite sine of x
right it's minus sine of x
minus sine of x
and then we can multiply both sides by
dx and you get
du
is equal to
minus sine
of x
dx i just multiplied both sides by dx
and then if we'll up here we have sine
of x dx we don't have minus sine of x dx
right
there we have sine of x dx i mean we
could have rewritten this top integral
as we could have rewritten it like this
sine
of x
dx
all of that over cosine
of x squared right so if we want to
substitute for this here we have a minus
let's multiply both sides of this by a
negative 1 and you get minus d u
is equal to sine
of x
dx
and let's see we know so let's rewrite
this original problem now i know i'm
running out of space
let me rewrite it so we know that u is
equal to cosine of x so let's do that
so now this integral becomes in the
denominator instead of cosine of x
squared
u is cosine of x that's u right we made
that definition so that's over u squared
right cosine of x becomes u
and then sine of x dx
sine of x dx right up there what is that
equal to well we just solved for it here
that's equal to minus d u sine of x dx
is equal to minus du so that we can
replace with this minus du
and then of course this has the exact
same form as this thing right here you
can rewrite this this is equal to
1 over let's say -1
over
u squared
d u
or we could rewrite this i'm just
writing it a bunch of different ways
whatever is easier for you to
conceptualize the same thing as
minus u to the minus 2
d u
and then here
we do the same thing we did up here
although now we have a minus out front
that actually makes it a little bit
cleaner
to take the antiderivative
we raise u it was to the minus two power
let's raise it to
one power higher than that so minus two
plus one is minus one right
so it's u
to the minus
one power and then you wanna divide by
minus one and i'll do it explicitly here
minus one and then you had this negative
that was sitting out there before you
had this negative so that negative is
still going to be there
and of course you're going to have a
plus c
and you haven't you could view this as a
negative you know this is a negative 1
or this negative divided by a negative
they're going to cancel out
and so you're just left with u to the
minus 1
plus c or
1 over u plus c is the antiderivative oh
sorry we're not done yet that's just the
antiderivative of this and now we had
our substitution to deal with what was
our substitution that we started with u
is equal to cosine of x
so if u is equal to cosine of x this
thing is equal to
is equal to 1 over cosine
of x
plus
c
is equal to the antiderivative of our
original problem which was i'll put it
in green
sine of x
over
cosine
of x squared
dx there you go
see in the next video